what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have been getting a lot of info
about Deadpool 3 lately we've been
getting a lot of info about the MCU in
general we have a lot of news about the
new Fantastic 4 film the plot points of
it and possible castings for Reed
Richards and others which we'll talk
about later today so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss that but today we have
casting news about Deadpool 3 and some
details small but really awesome details
about the ending of Deadpool 3 and
surprise Cameo that could be possibly
popping up at the end so a lot to break
down including the news that Daniel
Radcliffe Harry Potter himself has been
cast for a secret role in Deadpool 3 now
if you've been in the community for a
long time or if you've simply just been
following the rumors and the leaks and
the news for a while you probably know
that Daniel Radcliffe's name has been
thrown out there a lot as far as one of
Marvel studios's choices to play the new
Wolverine for the new X-Men in the MCU
and this has been talked about for years
now so is he playing a variant of the
new Wolverine in the MCU meaning he is
not the Earth 616 Wolverine but a
different universe as Wolverine or could
it be something else well we've narrowed
it down to four options and two are
pretty cool but you'll have to let us
know what you think and you'll have to
let us know what you want who would you
like to see him play in Deadpool 3 Let's
dive into it but first reminder about
our giveaway if you want a chance to win
Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items all you got to do
is subscribe and leave a comment on our
videos we pick one winner at the end of
each month and the winner gets to pick
one item so according to The Insider
Daniel rpk who has a good track record
with Scoops Daniel Radcliffe has been
cast in Deadpool 3 for a secret role now
I'm assuming most people know who Daniel
Radcliffe is even if you don't know the
name he is mostly famous for playing
Harry Potter like I mentioned he had
been rumored to be in the running to
play the new Wolverine in the MCU for
years now and you may know and you may
have heard me say this before but Kevin
fige in Marvel Studios they meet with
actors plenty of times before they
decide on a perfect role for them
sometimes they meet with actors off and
on for five plus years it was kind of a
similar case with Jake Gyllenhaal Marvel
Studios wanted him in the MCU he wanted
to be in the MCU they met for years
until they finally decided that Mysterio
was the perfect role for him so they
very well could have been doing this
with Daniel Radcliffe and now that
Deadpool 3 is happening and we're going
to a lot of different universes and a
lot of different variant are going to be
shown perhaps it's the perfect
opportunity for him to jump in as
Wolverine and that is option one he is
going to be a variant of Wolverine from
Another Universe in Deadpool 3 now a big
plot point that we learned recently was
that Deadpool 3 is going to be adapting
some of the plot points from Secret Wars
battle world what we know about this so
far is that the TVA is going to be
taking heroes from Worlds that are being
destroyed due to incursions and they're
going to be taking these Heroes and
putting them all in one Universe on one
planet essentially battle World from the
comics except it doesn't look like it's
going to be made by Dr Doom it looks
like it's going to be made by the TBA
which is kind of unfortunate I know
we're all dying to see Dr Doom but it
makes sense continuity wise and
story-wise for the Multiverse Saga so he
could be playing Wolverine in Deadpool 3
a variant of Wolverine a lot of people
thought that he would pretty much be
perfect to play the role because of his
height according to Marvel's official
record Wolverine is 5'3 and weighs 300
lb largely thanks to adamantium of
course so he's short in the comics and
this is kind of the only problem people
really had with Hugh Jackman is
Wolverine Hugh Jackman is 6' three so
not 5-3 he's a whole foot taller than
Wolverine is in the comics but it didn't
bug most people because he's amazing at
being Wolverine and we're happy he's
returning in Deadpool 3 but the height
and the scruffiness that Daniel
Radcliffe can have made him a fan
favorite for a Top Choice of Wolverine
when these casting rumors started
several years ago now of course
everybody said well he's going to have
to buff up but that's What actors do
they get in shape for roles they gain a
lot of weight or they lose a lot of
weight that's their job and Daniel
Radcliffe could definitely do that to
play Wolverine so that's option one he
could simply be playing a variant of
Wolverine or even possibly just
Wolverine who knows he could be cast as
the main Wolverine of our main Earth 616
timeline because he could appear again
during and after Secret Wars we know in
the see you that some variants don't
look alike like Toby Maguire Spider-Man
and Tom Holland Spider-Man and Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man there's also
different genders of variants like Loki
and Sylvie however we do know that there
are variants who look exactly alike
think Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness and the few variants that we
saw in that film they all looked exactly
the same so it is 100% possible that he
could show up as a variant in Deadpool 3
but also go on to play simply the main
Wolverine for the MCU would you like him
as our new Wolverine would you do not
let us know what you think in the
comments down below now option two and
option three kind of fuse together a
little bit because option two is he
could simply be playing himself he could
simply be Daniel Radcliffe remember this
is Deadpool Deadpool breaks the fourth
wall he makes a lot of jokes so option
two and kind of option three is he could
appear to play himself SL Harry Potter
they're the same but kind of different
he could appear as himself and Deadpool
could make a Harry Potter joke like Hey
look it's Harry Potter but you know he
might not actually do anything he could
just simply appear as himself or he
could actually appear as Harry Potter as
crazy as that sounds but that is what
Deadpool 3 is seemingly going to be
about craziness in the Multiverse and
the Multiverse should in theory expand
beyond the MCU because it has the
potential to do that and it has the
potential to be just absolutely insane
which I think a lot of people want now
of course it's Marvel Studios and they
kind of have to keep it within their
properties of course but they can make
deals with other Studios and James gun
who is now the head of DC said that
years ago he pitched a crossover between
Marvel and DC he pitched this to Marvel
he pitched it to DC and they were kind
of about it and James gun has basically
said that it's going to happen at some
point and now that he's the head of DC
I'm thinking it is going to happen
pretty soon well maybe not soon maybe
within the next 10 years if we're lucky
but bringing characters from other
universes into the MCU is what the
Multiverse Saga can be about and if
there is any time or place to do this it
is definitely Deadpool 3 because then
Deadpool can call out the obvious and
Deadpool can make fun of it he can say
hey you're Harry Potter you're from a
completely different Universe you're not
even a superhero and I think fans would
really like this I think it would
actually go over pretty well I think it
would be pretty funny and it's totally
something that Ryan Reynolds could do so
options two and three are he could play
himself SL he could actually play Harry
Potter out of the three options so far
would you prefer him to play Wolverine
himself or Harry Potter let us know down
below now the other option is he could
simply just be playing playing an MCU
character he could be playing a
character that has already been
introduced at some point in time in the
MCU or he could be playing a completely
new one it would be kind of cool to see
him play a variant of maybe Iron Man of
Captain America maybe the Scarlet Witch
maybe he's a male variant of the Scarlet
Witch he is a wizard in Another Universe
Deadpool could definitely make fun of
that or he's playing a new character
perhaps an X-Men because we know a lot
of X-Men are going to be in Deadpool 3
perhaps he plays some sort of aarian
obviously besides Wolverine which is our
first option but maybe Cyclops maybe
Nightcrawler maybe Beast the really cool
thing about Deadpool 3 and kind of the
premise for the story is that anything
is going to be possible in this movie
especially if the TVA is going to be
combining several different universes
from the vast Multiverse then really if
you think about it it's kind of just up
to whatever Ryan Reynolds can create in
his head which we know is a lot and
again if there's any time to do this in
any place it is now in Deadpool 3 make
the movie crazy and before we talk about
the ending real quick quick let us know
what you think about those four options
in the comments down below do you like
one of them do you like none of them let
us know now as far as the ending for
this goes Alex Perez from the cosmic
circus.com and Daniel rpk have both
teased a little scene for the end of
Deadpool 3 Daniel rpk on Twitter posted
a picture of the Deadpool 3 Logo stating
Pizza Time in which Alex Perez replied
with a gift of the original Avengers in
the post credit scene for The Avengers
film eating schwarma now this is kind of
both ambiguous and kind of cryptic but
if we think about pizza time we think
about one person and that person is Toby
Maguire Spider-Man Daniel rpk also
responded to a comment that said no way
in which he responded simply home
obviously referring to no way home which
is another indication of Toby Maguire
being involved with this ending we have
also heard that Toby Maguire is possibly
going to be in Avengers Secret Wars and
we know that Deadpool 3 is going to
directly set up Avengers Secret Wars in
fact some insiders have said recently
that much like Avengers Infinity war was
its own film but obviously directly
connected to Avengers endgame and set up
the entire story for it Deadpool 3 is
very much going to be like Avengers
Infinity War its own film but set up the
events for King Dynasty and Secret Wars
so it looks like we could possibly
expect the return of Toby Maguire
Spider-Man in Deadpool 3 which is just
super exciting but go ahead and let us
know all of your thoughts about all of
this news in the comments down below do
you have a preference for Daniel
ratcliff's character if he truly does
appear in Deadpool 3 who do you think he
should play if not himself and what do
you think about Toby Maguire possibly
coming in the ending of Deadpool 3 or do
you think they're referring to someone
else let us know all of your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you can stay up to date
on all the latest MCU news of course you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
as well and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
woof